[Music]
tonight Oscar pistorius's told his
account of the evening he killed his
girlfriend was it possible
your version is so improbable that
nobody would ever think it's reasonably
possibly true
he's accused of being a selfish liar who
won't take responsibility for anything
you will blame anybody but yourself
good evening from the courthouse in
Pretoria Oscar Pistorius has spent a
second day of intense aggressive
cross-examination he's been told that
his version of events was not just
improbable it was impossible and the
prosecutor Harry now has portrayed
Pistorius as an egotist who was obsessed
with guns he's gone on to suggest that
the couple were having troubles with
their relationship and they argued in
the minutes before Oscar Pistorius shot
reeva Steenkamp
Lisa Holland has the story of the day in
court for Oscar Pistorius day 19 of his
murder trial was defined by a relentless
attack on his credibility he shot and
killed his girlfriend reeva Steenkamp on
Valentine's Day last year he says he
thought she was an intruder sue under
oath mr. Pistorius
his evidence was heard but not seen
prosecutor Harry nel began by
criticizing the athlete over an apology
he made to this Jan Camp family in court
on Monday you see mr. Pistorius in that
if you were wanting to do it why would
you create a spectacle in court in the
public domain in the public I apologize
and noting product why would you do that
well I haven't had the opportunity to
meet this young comes I don't think
they've been ready
it's been struggling to I don't know
what words I thought about saying to
them I don't I don't think half the
words I wanted to say to them came out
the way that I if I could have read
remember the eloquent speech and
apologize slim I would have done so but
I haven't had the opportunity to again
mister the studious you never thought
about thing you never thought how they
would feel sitting in the public gallery
of a port whilst you might get apology
did you think how they would experience
that or there's only matter about the
stories Oscar Pistorius the prosecution
dissected the meaning of a text message
from Miss teen camp to the athlete three
weeks before she died today was one of
my best friend's engagement and I wanted
to stay longer I was enjoying myself but
it's over now you were picked on me
incessantly so that's not what happened
the previous day you have picked on me
incessantly what is that it though you
wouldn't and you know mr. Pistorius we
don't have an area this is our voices
only boys we have picked on Nancy cently
must must mean what it says over daisies
in your relationship you picked on that
well what does it mean I had a very
close relationship with Riva there would
be people that will come and testify
that I didn't pick on her in any way I
understand what she writes yeah but I
was good to Riva I never picked on my
lady so she lied I don't think she lies
dead if you never picked on her and she
put it they leave a light we are living
a double standard relationship well you
could be mad it can be mad about how I
deal with stuff when you are very quick
to act called an office when you are
unhappy that wasn't the first instance
that she she spoke about this double
standard it's it's been a double
standard throughout your relationship if
I read it
I think this is the first time she
mentioned double standard my lady but it
lies that she feels that that is
sometimes how our relationship was was
it like that or was she wrong I think we
were very different people m'lady I was
maybe a bit more sensitive towards some
things and maybe she didn't speak to me
when something was hurting her and it
made her feel like they were double
standards in the relationship so did she
was correctly she was a lady you did
everything to throw tantrums in front of
people now tell me about that dandruff
I've never thrown a tantrum in front of
other people I've maybe brush Schriever
off at that function maybe at another
time when we were at Sports Awards her
knife we had a disagreement we explained
where we left I think she was feeling at
the time when she wrote this message she
was feeling upset and she exaggerated on
some of the things that she said I'm
scared of you sometimes why would she be
scared of you I think she's scared of
the feelings that she has for me in the
way that I rushed her off
just say that again she's scared of what
I think she's scared of the feelings
that we had that she had for me my lady
she says I'm scared of you sometimes and
how he snapped at me and of how you will
react to me it's obviously scared of of
the way that Aria she thinks she does at
times yeah so she's not scared about the
feeling she's scared about how you react
to what she she does that is what she's
scared about why why would you be scared
what did you do to hurt her feelings
about the way Audrey acts milady
shot at it scream at it no I never shot
it or screamed at her at least we know
that she felt that you keep the very bad
mother dear Eva was a person who stood
up for herself if she believed I treated
her badly I think that she had no effect
she wouldn't have been with me and he
snapped at the Reve on the boss we've
had arguments in the past m'lady
I don't know I guess I have got upset
with her in the past and something that
maybe she said oh I don't I've never
lost my temper or shafted after or if I
snapped meaning in the context it's that
she says here where she says our kid
snapped at and told my accents and my
voices are Nouri annoying I think if
they were other times that I'd said
today she would have brought it up with
me but I don't remember the prosecution
sought to portray Oscar Pistorius as an
irresponsible gun owner he's accused of
lying about an incident at a
Johannesburg restaurant when a gun he
was handling went off nobody else touch
that gun that's correct
buddy a shot winner that's correct
if that firearm is incapable of firing a
shot without somebody putting the
trigger who pulled the trigger
I'm not sure my lady what I am saying is
that I didn't have my finger on the
trigger
no you you can't say that I'm not sure
let us think who could have done that
was it the person sitting next to you I
don't think it would have been possible
for anybody sitting at the table to have
all I don't think it would have been a
possibility that someone would have
reached under the table and pulled the
trigger
whilst this is amazing really amazing
you fired that gun there is no other way
that but it could have been discharged
without you putting the trigger you are
like Oscar Pistorius was asked why he
had taken his gun on a boat trip the
olympian said he carried a loaded weapon
most of the time are you telling this
court it wasn't negligent of you to
leave your gun in the boat in at all
whilst you sweat I don't see it as being
negligent if you can anything it is that
not negligent I didn't there was no one
there that I thought would know one day
that would handle my farm or my
farmhouse next to the boats in the water
I don't see it as being negligent m'lady
you see again mr. Pistorius it's that
man it's a strategist I today you just
don't take responsibility for anything
you just don't do anything wrong
you know any commander would say it's
wrong why can't you do that what can't
you say it's wrong to do that you
incapable of using those words as far as
yourself a concept I understand my lady
and if it's seen as negligent in I
understand that and then I was wrong
milady
whoo so this in this instance you would
at least agree that it was negligent yes
milady
I see good Oscar Pistorius was
cross-examined about evidence already
given by two witnesses who said he fired
his gun out of the sunroof of a car the
olympians response led to a sharp rebuke
from the judge for the public gallery
both indicate that you fired through the
sunroof that is definitely alive that is
allowing my lady both of them
independently with tell that lie they
both took the stand
they both had different stories as to
why it happened as to where it happened
as to how it happened as to the reaction
that story was fabricated my lady it's
never happened it was not the truth but
it's a bad fabrication because they they
never spoke to each other team I heard
post them giving evidence that I had
heard communication well who told you I
don't recall Mele know me I apologize my
lady for laughing I won't do it again
but I was surprised by the odds
apologize sorry milady I hope it doesn't
happen again
it worked I apologize no now also an to
say something to people out there you
possibly think this is entertainment it
is not so please restrain yourselves is
that the gallery minute take a letter
yeah welcome back mr. Nell the
prosecutor took Oscar Pistorius through
a detailed review of painstaking review
of the night that he shot reeva
Steenkamp and he has some big questions
like why didn't he see his girlfriend
reeva getting out of bed that night who
moved items in his bedroom and if his
version of events was true there had to
have been a big conspiracy
mr. Nell made him relive the night of
the shooting
she prepared food that's correct m'lady
can you remember what you had for dinner
that was a chicken roughly seven hours
before she was killed
is it possible that she got up later and
went down to eat something without you
knowing it
I don't think so milady upstairs in the
room you busy with your iPad serving the
net the Internet what was the deceased
doing she was on the carpet m'lady as I
said before she was doing her stretches
and yoga exercises on the carpet your
prosthesis I put lifts my prosthesis
next to the bed m'lady
waiting today if you look at the bed on
the right hand side River was watching
TV and I was lying next to and I was
half looking at the pictures on her
phone with her we were looking at
pictures of homes spending the night in
bed just chatting when nobody was on the
iPad I said I've just said I was on the
iPad then well what you they with it
I said she was tired and she said no she
was she wasn't tired and so I lay on her
stomach and I just said to when you fall
asleep will you bring the fans in and
close the doors and she said yes and
they're not just learning her stomach
and I I had my arm around her legs and
he validly that's correct m'lady
she was lying there nobody was
undeniably well it's the third time not
that I've said I was on my iPad do you
know what wick woke you up
I don't remember milady I remember it
was humid and hot sand I was awake you
know set up and bid there was enough
light that I could bring pick up the fan
and place it on the floor when I drew
the curtains it was pitch black when you
woke up which is here either I
I remember her talking to me I didn't
look down I had my hands my head in my
hands my lady and she asked me if I
can't sleep and I said to her I couldn't
and I got out of my bed she's there
she's next in I'm 2 meters from you and
you you're telling the poor didn't see
her get up
I don't know how she got up out of it I
was in close proximity to but I didn't
see her get out of bed stranger didn't
did not see her get up you will agree
and she was with you it was pitch black
and it was behind me my lady so it's not
strange at all so she got up only after
you close the curtains because before
you close the curtains it wasn't pitch
black I don't know when she got up my
lady
before you close the curtains he wasn't
pitch black if you got up then you would
have seen her I wouldn't have seen her
my lady weeks it was behind me and he
didn't hear you didn't ya ya know I had
the fans blowing in my face the floor
fan I didn't have my legs on was that
the same hearts as my head I simply
picked up the phone and I placed it I
don't know when she got up now at least
you fighting the babe I'm not facing the
bed I'm facing the opposite direction
the TVs in the exact opposite direction
of the bed my lady so you walked over
the Devaney I wouldn't have walked over
the de very because the Devere wasn't on
the floor my lady as I said my lady the
duvet was not on the floor did you at
any table you don't do the floor it's
not you it's not River so the policeman
at all gave evidence at that when they
walked in there to the waivers on the
floor were lying was the river under the
device yes River was under the device I
was he saw that Rita had to divide over
the bottom parts of her legs and I
didn't have the duvet on me at all
that's interesting served later see I
didn't see River but I can now tell the
quote that the device was covering the
bottom part of the legs how do you know
that I could see that you very going up
and I presume it was a League Soccer and
from what I can remember that's what I
remembered my leg you see you your
deputy and you walk down the left-hand
side of the beds around the front of the
bed she did not pause you they no I
don't know when she possibly Monday did
you think because you would have seen it
that's that much that's great then I
don't know when she got out and paid my
lady no no no that's what you want to
say but I say if I book you not to know
it is impossible for me not to know my
lady it's it exclude something else she
did not get out of the bed on the right
hand side of me I don't know where she
got off so harsh she got out of the
Nellie you guys if she and I'll go
through all these questions if she got
out in the right hand side his baby
would have seen her I probably would
have sensed that she was there my lady I
agree with her also for the portrait
Knicks except your version we have to
remove the the vibe from that position
where it is at the moment on photograph
55 that's correct what they do because
as far as you concerned the delay was
under me that's great
my lady what else is wrong well the fan
couldn't have possibly been there my
lady because it's in the way of the
doors opening indeed I would have run
out onto the balcony my lady and we are
shorted for half that fan would have
been in the way so never happened so it
must have been moved it never happened
you see because mr. Pistorius your
version is a lie now we have to look for
a policeman they do the following that
moved it away to the carpet they'd move
the fan back that moved the curtain more
open those three things am i right
that's correct what else there were many
things that were moved here the fan was
one of them has never moved
you see mr. mr. Pistorius it was never
moved that dog was open when you
and the deceased from an argument I will
build my case to say that when you got
up yet an argument that's why she ran
away screaming
we cannot lead by witness evidence
because of one witness we would want to
Paul is dead what about the small effect
that should be on the photograph that's
correct okay so you forgot about that
one
why don't you forget about that one
because that's significant so he's got
four feet a policeman muster first move
the fan before we put the debate on that
particular position
that's correct male okay is this one
because Spira see Oh what is it that
that they would do all this to you why
would the police do all this I'm not
sure my lady the fact is is that things
were moved and things were placed we can
go through this file and look at all the
photos where things were at different
places you would defend all the way
there you see the most amazing thing is
yesterday when we showed you these
photographs you did not say that
why not I'm not sure if the multi-block
remains in a position which now you
cannot move that fan to the position
that you said you put it in we can see
the court can see the photograph
everybody can see the photograph can see
that the length of that cable it cannot
go to the milady that's not what I see
no the court will make up the court will
make a finding the fan isn't at its it's
not at its point that it's been reeled
out or pulled straight you keep trying
mr. Pistorius it's not working
your version is I said let me rather
than to pit it with you version is so
improbable that nobody would ever think
it's reasonably possibly true it's so
improbable nobody you would not convince
people that that what you think now
about the multi-plug nog movie and the
fan movie is reasonably possible it's
impossible a fourth day at this witness
box then for Oscar Pistorius and the
whole thing in cross-examination is
starting to come down to the moment that
he stood in front of this toilet door
and fired those four bullets to discuss
the day Alex Crawford our correspondent
in court and William Booth a South
African attorney good to see both Alex
hard to know where to start there was so
much today a huge number of traps and
and he seemed to walk into quite a few
of them one of them I thought he said
was all about the safety the gun safety
because he made a very big point he
keeps on jumping around which is another
tactic going from one charge to the
other but he laid out the case that you
are a gun enthusiast you did that gun
safety questionnaire you knew all about
guns and each time he's town asking
about him he's giving him a huge amount
of information showing his knowledge of
guns and you always carried it one up
and you always had the safety catch on
so if he had to undo that safety catch
on that night is that premeditation I
think that's probably the way Harry Nell
is gonna be going I'm William Booth when
it all comes down to four shots that
were fired and what was the state of
mind and what sort of a man fired those
shots the whole issue of the
cross-examination I think is important
you know many people Marc might wonder
why why such aggressive
cross-examination I think it's the style
of the person cross-examining and nel
seems to be a bit of a bulldog you know
he's in there trying to get the point
across but the judge is also there to
shoot to make sure that it's fair and
you can't be rude and you can't be
abusive I think that mustn't be
forgotten maybe the judge needs to come
in in my view a little bit more often to
kind of say we'll hang on just temper
this thing a little bit
when he moved on it's claw for thank you
both very much for your thoughts on an
action-packed day here in the court and
Oscar Pistorius going to spend a fifth
day in the witness spots tomorrow to
join us for that and tonight 9:30 and
every weekday night our special program
with all the main evidence of the day on
Sky News
[Music]